Hi all, and welcome to the RCA Q&
A application Pot demo,
a tool designed to reimagine how we
interact with our data.
At its core,
the tool introduces a straightforward
chat interface designed to turn static,
intricate data sets into interactive,
conversational insights.
Users can ask questions in a natural
language and receive either direct
answers or detailed analytical insights
instantly.
This empowers decision making by allowing
users to talk to their data,
receiving both visual and contextual
responses that drive faster,
more informed strategies.
By merging advanced AI with an intuitive
chat based UI,
this solution bridges the gap between
overwhelming datasets and actionable
business intelligence.
Now let's see the tool in action.
Let's begin with the question about
CBRE's global market share in 2024.
You could see that CBRE held a global
market share of 4.43% in 2024.
Now,
let's look at the number of deals CBRE
has made in the city of Dallas in 2024.
Looks like there are 17 deals closed in
Dallas in 2024.
Now,
let's examine CBRE's market share in
Europe over the last five years.
Presented in USD,
the line graph clearly shows a
fluctuation,
providing a visual representation of
trends over the years.
Colliers led the market with 9 deals,
followed by emerged Capital Partners with
three deals in Australia in 2024.
CBRE and JLL each closed.
The bar chart here compares the number of
deals closed by each broker,
making it easier to see Colliers leading
position.
Thank you for exploring the RCA Q and A
application pot demo and have a nice day.